[Music]
i'm kristin shaffer i'm an outdoor
adventurer and travel photographer and
I've been living on the road for almost
two years now full time traveling and
working and I was previously living in
an SUV and I loved living up the road so
much that I bought a van and decided to
build a house it's my home slash office
on wheels and I'd love to meet you guys
too
[Music]
welcome to my van what I really wanted
to achieve with this band besides having
a mobile office and a place to live was
I wanted it to be my home on wheels like
as similar to my last apartment as
possible this is the same tile
backsplash that I had in my kitchen and
I had great coaches in my apartment
these are even the same throw pillows
that I had just the whole white and gray
color scheme I wanted it to be very zen
and calming and kind of a retreat from
crazy chaotic life on the road
the build itself was done by gone at the
Van Breton Yuliya and did an incredible
job and if you want to check out the
details of the electrical setup the
solar how it was actually built from day
one you can head over to their channel
and I'll link to that below right as you
walk in you see the kitchen here and
these countertops are solid birch
hardwood that have been hand painted to
give it this great just stressed look
and then all the cabinets are painted in
vanilla shake right up here this is my
little bookshelf which I love it extends
all the way back there down here we have
a two burner stove very exciting and
here is where I keep like my cutting
board and my towels and then secret
drawer coloring this is my Dometic
fridge which love because there's plenty
of space and it can actually have a
freezer up here too I removed it because
I end up filling it with produce most of
the time but it's temperature controlled
and it fits all so down here is where I
keep all of my power stuff and honestly
I can't remember all the specs should I
try I have to 100 amp lithium batteries
here and those are connected to the
solar panels up top which I have to 160
watt solar panels for energy and then
here I have an inverter which is kind of
amazing it charges all the things I can
have my laptop charging camera batteries
my drone batteries my hairdryer my hair
straightener all of the things I have
switches throughout and they're also on
a dimmer which is really nice and like
here in the kitchen these two over here
for the bedroom and then there's also
one over here outlets here they're down
there in the office space behind the
driver seat here and there's also one in
the back in case I want to work outside
down in this cabinet I have the three
cloth storage bins that I picked up from
Target and they just have very stuff and
then it's like this one is oil fuel cups
this one just has pots and pans and
Tupperware random stuff this is my yoga
mat more random camera gear so this
right here I just picked up at Target
and I custom cut them for each of the
cabinets and these are really great
because they keep everything in place
what I'm driving like nothing moves and
this massive drawer here is just extra
storage and up here is where I keep my
food so I just have these cloth storage
bins that I picked up from Target and
somehow they fit perfectly and yeah just
have food stash up there and then over
here here's my pasta strainer Tupperware
bowls middle grocery bag and here I have
my arrow press for coffee which I use
every day and I also use this every day
to make coffee and it's one of my
favorite things that I found for the van
it's a collapsible electrical water here
thanks
next to the this little dog which is
just like snacks and granola bars and
stuff I have these two books and my
super top secret what looks like a book
that's actually super sexy receipts I've
had this since I lived in Italy ten
years ago seven years ago no seven years
the mannequin on this side I have my
sink and I actually love that it's
separate from this counter because it
gives me so much countertop space it's a
deeper sink with a full-size faucet
which I opted for because sometimes I
just like to throw in my dirty dishes
and cover it up and then roll out of a
location without all of the cleaning
okay so the water tanks or the sink very
accessible so I have two five gallon
tanks here there's a gray water tank
installed underneath the van and there
are switches to empty that out really
easily I'll show you that's next for the
gray water tank underneath and also the
sink here we have a super handy dandy
little switch board this one powers the
sink which just kidding there we go
and then this other switch here all I do
is flip it and then the gray water tank
underneath which is all of the water
that comes out of the sink and goes down
the drain will just automatically empty
out and then this is just oh oh
middle room I use this everyday like
five times a day this is my cleaning
supplies slash junk drawer for the man
I have a candle another candle fairy
lights microfiber towel lint roller Oh
actual cleaning supply the world's
cutest little heater it's a whole bunch
of garbage bags crap and a toothbrush
which I should probably never use right
next to this cabinet underneath the sink
we have all of the plumbing down here
which you can't really see because it's
full of baby wipes super essential when
you live on the road
I have mini baby wipes and then also
more cleaning supplies paper towel and
this little garbage can which I actually
also had in the Nissan Xterra and some
people ask me why didn't you get a
bigger trashcan like you live in a van
Dijk have space but I like keeping the
smaller one because it just makes me
more mindful of how much trash I'm
creating so there's my cute little and
dog here in this super secret
compartment is a drawer with my toilet I
honestly don't know how are you slow
without this thing but you guys it's
it's number one up here is another
product from Dometic and this is a fan
it's super dirty right now sorry I
should really clean that if I have this
open and these back windows open with
screens then it creates this really nice
airflow which can be a lifesaver when
it's super hot outside the ceiling so
it's all made of natural hardwood and
it's been hand-painted to give it that
gray and white distressed look this here
is my office slash bedroom slash
chilling area this table is on a lagoon
mount so I can move it wherever I want
I can also just completely remove this
table if I want and that will give me
all this extra space up here in these
cabinets it is where I keep all my
clothes so I found these cost storage
bins at Target and they fit so perfectly
which is kind of amazing like socks
underwear bathing suit leggings workout
clothes and then real pants which I've
pretty much never wear and like dresses
and stuff like that and then
this side I have sweaters t-shirts tank
tops and this one and this one I keep
all of my toiletries this one is my
little jewelry box and back here I have
this super compact little mirror so
though so at night when I want to make
the bed this pops off and sits perfectly
right in here and then these cushions
here in the back fit snugly right here
and it makes a bed that's slightly
larger than a queen-size bed okay
underneath the benches here is storage
and under this bench I keep all of my
bedding here's my down comforter here's
an extra blanket and this little baby
blanket and then sheets and random down
parka but this down here is my mattress
topper which I put on top of the bed at
night just so that I don't peel the
cracks from the cushions so overall it's
four inches of latex mattress super
comfortable on this side under this
bench I have some extra clothes storage
and these cubes parka here's my suitcase
and I just have like duffel bags and a
few other toiletries stuff like that and
under this cushion I have more storage
that's where I keep all of my camping
gear and then I also have some
compartments back here but it's so I can
access it from the inside but it's way
easier to access from the back
camping gear and my tripod and stuff
like that so it's easily accessible and
one really cool thing about this drawer
is the great tabletop fits perfectly
right here so if I want to work outside
and have a tabletop and I also have an
outlet here for my laptop these
just make these compartments a little
more accessible and over here blankets
extra propane that's whole thing I
already showed you guys this cabinet but
down here in this drawer is where I keep
most of my shoes which I like having it
accessible from the outside because if
I've been out hiking or something and my
shoes are really dirty or wet I can just
throw them in here so coming back into
the van we have this overhead storage
which runs all the way up to the front
windshield and up here I have two zero
Degree sleeping bags all my down jackets
brain jackets extra backpacks my
backpacking backpack mittens hats all
the things there and have easy access to
go up here here behind the driver's seat
I have punch in back which I have a tops
with a carabiner here and then I have my
laundry bag put in back here down here I
have my camera bag and here I have my
newest addition to the van which is a
travel guitar and I'll be honest I have
no idea how to play it one day I'm gonna
play it that Howard song for you guys
[Music]
I had a swivel package installed so I
can turn it around and sit right here
kind of eyesore just like a change of
scenery and an extra seat in the house
up in this storage area is where I keep
the covers for all of my windows and
they roll up really nicely they're gray
on one side to match the van interior
and then black on the other side so it's
a complete block out if you're looking
into the van at night and there's
reflectix on the inside which keeps the
van cool during you know when it's hot
out and then it also keeps it warm if
it's cold out and there are magnets sewn
into the side here tada
super dark also I'm down here under the
driver's seat is plenty of space and
that's where I keep my tools have a jump
starter and I have my tire inflator and
just anything that I might need for
general van maintenance or if I get
stranded on the side of the road
somewhere and this curtain up here is a
blackout curtain so I can pull this shut
at night and this combined with the
covers on the back and all the windows
it's like pitch black in here and I
sleep like a baby
so that's it guys thank you for watching
and if you enjoyed this video please
like and subscribe and yeah if you have
any ideas or questions about van life
drop them in the comments below and I'll
see if I can include them in future
videos also if you're interested in
check out my photography and you can
find me on Instagram at Christian
Schaffer
[Music]
[Music]